[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
this morning on the dish we head to San
Francisco where Chef David neefeld has
shown you can come home again the Bay
area native and Son of Soviet Jewish
immigrants was classically trained first
at The Culinary Institute of America
then in some of the finest kitchens in
the U.S and Europe through work and
travels nafld found a connection with
food that he wanted to pass on to diners
it's what's behind his award-winning
restaurant kafico described as Italian
cuisine through a California lens as for
the name itself colloquially it means so
cool which at K FICO pretty much
describes every aspect
San Francisco's K FICO is a feast for
the senses
all of the senses it's loud and vibrant
and the food is unpretentious and
Unapologetic and we are very very
serious about the quality but we're not
very very serious about ourselves no
talking just eating chef and co-owner
David neefeld opened the Italian Taverna
four years ago with business partner
Matt Brewer in nafld's words it was
Kismet the second that I walked in this
former auto body shop and the skylights
were beaming through and I saw the
vaulted ceilings and I saw the big sign
with the arrow on it I got chills down
my spine and I felt like for the first
time I said this is really where my
restaurant needs to be I need to be here
so pasta out as for the food I wanted to
cook food that I wanted to eat daily I
wanted a restaurant where I could see
regulars and I wanted crave ability
nafeld calls the cuisine rustic finesse
something you'd find in a small cabin in
the Italian Countryside or a Tuscan
Villa dishes like chicken marsala and
Margarita Pizza with a crust befitting
San Francisco or even the Cucina ibrakea
kfiko's Jewish Cuisine which honors the
chef's Heritage we have our kind of
Roman Jewish ghetto staple which is a
souply risotto rice on the inside and
then when you break it it's melty cheese
a street food it's just one of the most
delicious and kind of comforting things
you could ever eat oh my God nafeld grew
up in San Francisco his parents escaped
religious persecution in the Soviet
Union fleeing to Rome before settling in
the U.S the great thing was that they
looked at my brother and I and said you
know we've made all these sacrifices and
we had a dream for you guys to be able
to live the lives you wanted to live so
do the things that make you happy don't
do things only for money I'm good with
the beagley and I'm good with the
Mezzaluna for nayfeld it turned out to
be a little of both finding happiness
and money washing dishes at a local
restaurant school was just never
something that connected right for me I
just missed everything that was said
and it was just painful for me to sit in
a classroom the second I walked into a
kitchen
I was pointing at a stack of pots and
pans grease everywhere soap suds coming
over the edge of the dish pit and I just
felt it I felt like I was in my place I
understood what what was going on and it
just made sense from that moment he says
ADHD was what made Traditional School so
difficult but when he got to culinary
school everything changed I had never
done well in math I had never done well
in geography never done well in science
the second that you applied any of those
things
with the filter of food wine and
hospitality
all of a sudden my mind was able to pick
it up from The Culinary Institute of
America nafel began to build a resume
few can match working in world-renowned
kitchens like Nobu 11 Madison Park and
the Mansion among the things he learned
refinement an eye for excellence and an
unwillingness to compromise on
excellence and on integrity
the manifestation was kafico where
nayfeld says he found his true voice as
a chef creating Connection by using
seasonal and market-driven foods like
the sun gold tomato in San Francisco Bay
anchovy salad or a simple small melon
plate with olive oil basil and mint they
sing together as harmonious and I think
that that's the key to our Cuisine
really is this
idea of finding finesse the sweet corn
trangoli another perfect example pureed
sweet corn inside handmade pasta topped
with corn chanterelle mushrooms and
chives I love this this to me this is
summer flavors so once again simplicity
not over adorning it not trying to show
Too Many techniques
the technique is the quality of pasta
the Perfection of the cook
in the sourcing of the ingredients right
very very simple and while nafld clearly
takes pride in each bite dark chocolate
and hazelnuts it's one of my favorite
pairings
he admits his priority shifted when he
became a father to now three and a half
year old Elena my restaurant functions
without me every single day the team
that we've cultivated here is incredibly
talented that's why it works and and it
works because they're incredibly
talented they buy into the ethos and the
values we compensate incredibly well
which is something that I cannot you
know State enough which is fair
compensation is tantamount to our
industry moving forward
it's why kefiko raised its wages and its
prices post pandemic we've been able to
include a profit sharing model with our
team we distributed seventy thousand
dollars from one quarter of profits to
our staff folks who have been here for a
number of years managers dishwasher
found a house back house everybody what
we're doing is we are really creating a
space for people to come to learn and to
have Security in themselves and in their
lives and not feel like they have to
sacrifice every shred of human dignity
in order to just be here what do you
hope somebody who comes in here just to
dine walks away with simply put I just
want people to enjoy the moment right
and I want you to order something that
makes you happy I don't necessarily need
people to be batted over the head with
the fact that we roll every sheet of
pasta by hand and we make Ragu over 12
hours and that we put 36 months
parmigiano reggiano on you know those
are all things that we know for our own
satisfaction of our craft of our metier
the guests should just know that they
love it and that they're enjoying it and
that's all
and you know he's doing all these things
in his restaurant but also fighting for
other restaurants and and those in the
food service industry to start to make
some of this more normal those wages The
increased wages so that this doesn't
have to be about only the privileged or
you can't afford to do this job what was
so interesting he said that his
employees bought into the ethos and
values and that's what makes this
incredible team what seemed to be
evident with him and with so many others
doing well post-pandemic is that they
bought in to their staff that's right
that's exactly it you have to pay them
more because there's so many
opportunities for them and it's so
difficult for every restaurant now to
still Define work exactly a dry Negroni
cheers
sorry the food does not travel from
there as well but I brought you a drink
right nice